all right so here we are with this live
picture from our camera on top of the
red rock resort and it is a little bit
windy it's going to get windier and we
have some lingering cloud cover you may
have even seen a sprinkle and i don't
think we're completely done with it
we'll check the radar here in just a
moment we're holding it 52 degrees with
this blanket of cloud cover but what's
happening in your neighborhood that 52
is the official temp at reed
international got the 40s and with
southerly winds of 15 to 20 miles an
hour you're taking a walk walking the
dog or whatever it's going to feel more
like the low 30s to the upper 20s there
been a little bit of snow up at lea
canyon not as much as they wanted but
they'll take whatever they can get right
now sunrise mountain you're at 50 same
with mountains edge and roads ranch down
in the southwest seven hills and anthem
you're also at 50 to nevada and beyond
now winter weather advisories continue
for lincoln county and southwestern utah
parts of northwestern arizona kingman
you're at 36 right now you'll see a mix
of rain and snow throughout the day
today over the hump and prompt good
morning with your 46 hello beatty you're
at 40 29 in tonopah now it is the last
day of 2021 we think it'll end up being
mostly sunny but clouds and wind will
blow in during the day today then it
will be back to sunshine for the first
day of 2022 we'll try for 55 today
normal high would be 56 so hour by hour
smoke advisory has been issued by clark
county winds gusting to 25 at 8 o'clock
we'll make 48 feel like 38 47 at 10 p.m
will feel like 37 and at the stroke of
midnight gusts to 30 miles an hour would
affect the fireworks ted florendra will
be checking in for the hour by hour
updates through tonight so scattered
sprinkles moving on as this area of low
pressure pushes out the north wind will
pick up for your family and friends snow
across the midwest and the good news for
those fires outside of denver they are
expecting some snow today the eight day
forecast after 55 today officially the
morning low for new year's day 37 only
47 with those north breezes continuing
upper 20's saturday night into sunday
and then the first week of the new year
temperatures rise back up close to 60.